June 2014.
Aerial cameras capture a riverbed in South
Texas.
Nothing unusual.
But when the same river is photographed the
following day, something appears in the mud.
These spots are very out of place.
Like they don't belong there.
They could almost be like really large
footprints.
They're huge.
These are the footprints of a monster.
Zoologist Roland Kays studies the image.
He believes that the beast that left these
prints walks on two legs.
Based on the pattern, it looks like they're
created by a bipedal creature, but it's got
to be something way bigger than a human.
It's possible that these footprints are
actually maybe bears standing up on hind legs
or something like that.
But even the biggest black bears create
prints just nine inches long, too small to be
seen from space.
So the question is what caused them?
What left them there?
The image comes to the attention of Wildlife
Tracker Baltimore Galvan.
Galvan analyzes the footprint in the picture
in an effort to reconstruct the scene.
It looks like it was actually coming out of
the foliage right through here.
And he probably saw something around this
area right up here.
The shape and pattern of the footprints are
unlike anything he has come across.
It raises a lot of questions.
He's walking forward like this and then all
of a sudden from here, he just starts picking
up speed like it's actually running.
It's very, very fascinating.
But there's only so much information to be
gleaned from the image.
I have to go down over there and just check
it out for myself.
If I misidentify something.
Then my reputation is gone.
He and his partner had 400 miles to the
stretch of the Blanco River, which is
captured in the image.
In the area. There have been several reports
of strange sounds and sightings of unusual
creatures. Galvan stops off to speak to some
witnesses.
Tell me exactly what you heard.
It was a weird sound.
I'd say it was about nine foot tall, and it
was all hairy.
It was covered in hair.
There was nothing that wasn't hair.
I did not see the face.
We had to bend.
Another another couple of feet taller than
me.
Well, and.
I'm kind of like, spellbound.
What the heck was that?
Could reported sightings like these have
anything to do with the giant footprints in
the satellite image?
The animal described in the reports does
resemble a large beast known to have existed.
This thing sounds like a creature called
gigantic Pythias, which was actually real.
This thing was ten feet tall.
It weighed £1,200 and it was related to
orangutans.
It's the largest ape that scientists know
about.
So just imagine, like a giant orangutan
wandering around the earth.
But scientists believe gigantic epidemics
died out thousands of years ago.
When it comes to the pictures, it's always
blurry or difficult to see.
So the concrete evidence is not there.
People have been looking for Bigfoot for
decades.
If we haven't found incontrovertible
evidence yet, does it really exist?
Matching the satellite image with his GPS.
Galvan finds the section of river where the
prints were captured.
The footprint should be right up ahead.
And this as far as we can go with the
vehicle.
Right? Blanco.
This stretch of river is isolated and rocky.
The prints are not at all what Galvan was
expecting.
Well, this is amazing.
Breathtaking.
Galvin's monster hunt takes a strange turn.
They're not fresh at all.
These tracks have been here for a very, very
long time.
For a very long time.
This animal is way bigger than I expected.
This one here, It's like five feet long and
four foot across.
Up close, Galvan realizes this is no two
legged beast.
This monster walks on four legs.
The prints are gigantic.
This thing is immensely big and heavy.
I don't know the species of the animal that
made these tracks, but all that I know is a
huge animal.
Many times bigger than the biggest elephant.
There is only one kind of creature that
could possibly leave footprints like this.
This is another mystery that we have here.
I don't know what kind of dinosaur made
these tracks.
All that I know is a huge animal.
So what have we got here?
Photographs are sent to a team of experts
for analysis.
So how long is one of these a given track
here?
They're about three feet across and about
three feet long.
Examination of the animal's gait, the size
of the prints and the shape of the feet leads
the scientists to an extraordinary
conclusion.
These are sauropod tracks.
Sauropods were the largest dinosaurs ever to
have roamed the earth.
This monster herbivore was 100 feet long,
stood 60 feet high with a neck six times
longer than a giraffes.
It weighed over 60 tons.
Can you imagine a herd of these thundering
through your neighborhood?
Even though there are gigantic, they were
actually vegetarians.
They walk together in groups roaming around
in Texas.
Further analysis of the riverbed reveals over
90 individual tracks.
You could imagine them coming down to this
riverbed perhaps to get something to drink.
Sauropods were so massive.
Only the mighty T-Rex dared to take them on
an ambush predator.
The T-Rex would choose locations like
riverbanks to mount an attack.
This herd of dinosaurs wouldn't have been
alone.
There would have been predators hiding in
the bushes and trees.
The team studies the local geology to guess
when these prints might have been made.
The geology on it shows that they are about
100 million years old.